Jamie is in st. Louis hi Jamie how are
you your muffled I can't understand
you're going to speak directly into your
phone please
is that better yes ma'am thank you okay
we have paid all 15,000 and that so far
thank you yeah but we were really dumb
well I would say we still are dumb we're
still learning so and then we spend a
lot more to go but recently I've
noticing our electric bills went up and
up enough enough and on budget billing
and I never really paid attention to our
bills before until just recently
whenever it was brought to my attention
that were like six hundred and fifteen
dollars behind our budget billing amount
so every month or every six months they
evaluate this and Ameren told me that
that amount is going to go up another
hundred dollars we're already paying two
hundred and fifty dollars a month on our
budget billing it's going to go up to
three hundred and fifty dollars come
November and it will continue to rise
until we're meaning that the amount that
we're supposed to be paying so my
concern here I asked and then what I
should do they told me according to
their energy yardstick my house is
reading a zero point five on a scale of
zero to 10 10 being the best
my house is weary and not efficient so
they told me the best thing to do would
be getting a new furnace and AC new
windows and insulate my attic again
where I'm babysitting the [ __ ] you
emergency's huh all for a hero yeah I'm
just trying to figure out room for this
an AC in finance or should I just keep
paying what I'm paying I'm doing what
I'm doing I mean you don't have money
for long so I don't really know what I
should do yes you do yeah you're trying
to get out of that hole while you're at
the bottom
you can't go spend $15,000 to save $100
okay think about it yeah windows windows
are new furnace i new heating there and
new insulation it's 20 grand you know
what's your need to I just gave them to
you what's your house worth it's for 115
so I see about 115 yeah okay well how
much dad do you have alone how much dad
do you have left
I'd say at least 20 and 20 thousand left
and you've already paid off 15 since
December yeah so that means by spring
your debt free right that's where you're
headed that's where you're headed
what's your household in yeah all right
so what would I do if I were in your
shoes I'd pay my light bill and I'd get
out of debt okay now when you're out of
debt and you have your emergency fund in
place if you want to do some upgrades on
your house then you look at return on
investment return on investment means if
I spend $1,000 and I make $1 a year back
on my electric bill that means it takes
me a thousand years to get my money back
well if I spend $1,000 and I knock a
thousand dollars a year off my light
bill it takes me one year to get my
money back do you see what I'm doing yes
so then you will break this down into
three categories
his windows eating there and insulation
and you would get bids after you have
the money to pay cash and you would look
at the bid and the bid is $26,000 to do
all of this stuff no break it down how
much of the windows going to lower the
light bill and get the actual get a
lower the electricity bill get the
actual numbers okay most of the things
you're describing are probably not going
to give you a return on investment while
you live in that house you're not gonna
live there long enough you may not live
life long enough to get all the money
back so but you can look at it look at
it and go okay I can do a heating and
air system here for $7,500 and it'll
save me $100 a month so that's 75 months
okay and you go you know are we gonna be
here what five six seven years does it
take you that long to break even
you know how fast am I put this money
out how fast am I gonna get it back it
is not going to increase the value of
your home equal to what you spend okay
nothing that was my question I didn't
know it doesn't know I'm like okay
because all the homes in your
neighborhood had the same heating air
system the same windows in the same
insulation unless someone's upgraded
them so you know if your home is worth
115,000 it's worth a hundred fifteen
thousand as it sits and then when you
start spending this money on it the
question is did he go you know he's a
buyer gonna walk up and go oh these
people spent twenty eight thousand
dollars on this energy package and so
we're gonna not pay a hundred and
fifteen we're gonna pay a hundred and
forty I don't think so that's not gonna
happen and you can talk to your real
estate agent and start doing research on
that but all of that happens when you're
ready to pay cash today you don't have
the money so your light bills going up a
hundred bucks oh well life goes on and
you're still gonna get out of debt next
spring and you're still going to build
your emergency fund and then you're
gonna look at the analysis and say how
quickly do I break even on these
purchases what is my return on
investment and that's how you look at it
and it's because you know if you're not
careful you go oh god the light we have
a hundred box and you
you spent forty fifty thousand bucks
twenty-eight thousand bucks eighteen
thousand bucks whatever that you'll
never get your money back on or maybe it
has a great return on investment you get
your money back in eighteen months and
if you did that would be like awesome
but that would be saving your entire
life bill plus money they're gonna pay
you so that really wouldn't work that's
not going to happen so anyway you just
got to back it out and look at what your
savings is versus your cost and and it
has to be real and then you do the
analysis and some insulation packages
are worth that some window packages are
worth that but today you don't have the
option unto it because you got to get
out of debt and you got to build your
emergency fund you get so money pay cash
for this the stuff you've gots working
run it through thanks for calling in one
of the biggest challenges to getting out
of debt is to make the decision that
never borrow again you can't get out of
a hole while you dig out the bottom
people this is the Dave Ramsey show